hello everyone I know you only enjoyed
those games by allele at chess
zero but it's time to return to some
good old human and human action and what
game to do it better with then Veselin
Topalov versus Shockley remedy are from
round four of the sham gear chess
tournament which is basically a memorial
tournament in honor of Wooga nooga she
moved great as a rejoining grandmaster
and it's quite an interesting game
because they play well Madera chooses a
line that he is very comfortable with
and that he plays for his entire life
but it takes a magician like Veselin
Topalov to show him some interesting
variations in it as you see in the game
and I do have something prepared for you
it's there a lifetime record so and this
is a record including this game so it's
3 to 3 with 9 draws this is including
classical games and if you include rapid
slash exhibition games
the result is 6 to 6 with 13 rows so
vestment appositive Topalov has an equal
score against chakra mama Dee ro and it
well as you know resident Apollo dropped
from the world's top 20 rated chess
players because he played one batch
tournament but he did get invited to
Shanker because well obviously the
organized a chunker realized that having
T'Pol of playing their tournament can
only be a plus for their tournament so
let's see this game Veselin has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have E 5 Knight to f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 Duru Lopez a6 we have once
again more fees defense Bishop to a
fortnight to f6 castles knights to e4
capturing the pawn and the pole goes for
d4
another way you can cut you can play
this line is about going immediately
rook to e1 attacking attacking this
night and when the knight moves
captured the night the pawn captures and
then Knight captures on e5 Bishop to e6
and d4 but as both of these lines are
pretty much completely analyzed it's
merely a matter of taste so this one
goes for d4 we have b5 now attacking the
bishop bush would be 3 D 5 and
d captures on e5 grabbing back the pawn
Bishop to e6 Bishop to e3 and Bishop to
e7 c3 always a full move in pretty much
every variation of the rule opus gaining
more control of the d4 space making room
for a bishop and c2 when the Knight
attacks and via Knight a5 so mommy tiara
of castles we have a nice to d2 and
Knight captures Queen captures and
Knight to a5 now as we've discussed push
up the c2 and now Knight the c-4
attacking the Queen Queen to d3 and now
the great question can black capture the
b2 pawn with the night
well if black did this you would get
Queen - h7 checkmate of course that
would be that would be ridiculous so the
answer is No
first my media up stops this we have g6
and now White has to make a decision his
Bishop is attacked and e3 his own now
really is attacked on b2 as there is no
more Queen age 7 so taking these two
things into consideration one would
obviously play Bishop to c1 and this is
what my media of was expecting at the
time this game was played top olive
needs to make his 15th move and the
pallav does not go Bishop the c1 rather
top olive goes Bishop to h6 and what
what is this this is basically a spit in
the face move the pollo is giving up
it's a clean pawn on b2 yeah
you can just grab it and it's exactly
what my Medea of does night capture some
b2 attacking the Queen so top Allah
gives up gives up a pawn to make the
game interesting and we all know to
Paulo is that kind of guy Queen to e2
getting the Queen out of the way and now
rook to e8 getting the rogue colored
Waifs so basically the night is a bit
misplaced but one move the knight can
easily get back into the game and
Mamedov snatched a pawn
so what did the pollo get are this well
so far it seems like a silly pawn
sacrifice the pallav now plays nice to
d4 and okay
it does have some poison to it
the threat is Knight to c6 you want to
attack the Queen and get rid of the dark
square Bishop if you're able to get rid
of mama doors dark square Bishop then
black King would indeed
feel the draft as all of these dark
squares around the king would be weak
only top Allah would have a dark square
bishop then maybe the point sacrifice
would be justified but of course
Mohammed Arab is not going to allow this
Bishop to d7 and now comes f4 so what do
you do here you don't really have time
for a slow move as f5 is coming you
don't have time to bring the knight back
so my major goes for the active c5
kicking the night away Knight to f3 and
now Queen to b6 Queen to b6 preparing c4
in some variations again developing the
Queen and preventing Topalov from
playing Bishop captures on g6 and then
picking up the night on b2 grabbing back
the pawn I don't think top Allah would
actually do this unless it was like
really important for the game but it's
an extremely strong Bishop and this
night is just looking silly there but
Queen the Queen to b6 definitely
prevents this as now if the better of
capture screen captures and then white
didn't really gain much
Queen to f2 not allowing c4 as the Queen
um b6 is unprotected
we have d4 Bishop to g5 now and here D
captures on c3 and the pollo goes for
Queen to h4 so giving up more material
and just to bring the Queen into the
attack
we have c4 with check King to h1 and now
mama Derek again has to has them make a
decision if if you capture the piece
just to relieve the attack it's not
really doing much a knight captors in g5
u rh 7 points attack you have to push h5
here and then after 94 comes Knight f6
is the threat and the engine the engine
actually says that this is this isn't
all that dangerous for black but I'm
sure if you ask my Musharraf mom yah he
would agree that you don't want to play
this position against Apollo would black
so after King to h1 Bishop to f8 getting
the bishop out of e7 as it was attacked
twice and preparing to remain over it
into the defense
f5 immediately topalov is unstoppable
here we have night 2 D 3 it's very hard
to find a reasonable move here for black
but the night on b2 is pretty useless so
you kind of want to get it back into the
game and this this kind of nullifies the
power of this Bishop and c2 now it's not
really doing anything it can it can
capture this Knight but this will only
improve black's pawn structure e six now
and now you can see that it's very hard
to find a move for black so what do you
do here if you play something like f
captures on e6 you immediately get F
captures and g6 and now you lose the
game Queen captures on h7 is a terrible
threat after h6 simply captures captures
captures now Queen to h7 is a threat
followed by Queen to f7 checkmate you
have to stop this Ruki seven and now
after captures captures you get Knight
to g5 the threat is once again the rope
to f7 once you once you prevent this
maybe make some room for your king and
now comes knife to f7 you threaten Queen
- Queen to h8 checkmate after King moves
now 95 check King moves back and now
rook finally comes to f7 and it's all
over here that's right ace Queen
captures and g7 and after rook captures
pawn captures and f7 this is checkmate
now so this isn't the only variation at
least the checkmate what all of them
lead to checkmate and that would be very
very uncomfortable to play if you played
F captures on e6 so my mural has to give
up a piece here but he did grab a lot of
points so it's not really like he's down
a piece F captures any six and now rook
captures on e6 so the pollo is now up a
piece but you know it's it's safe to say
that among media of definitely has
compensation with with his beautiful
Queen side majority the pollo basically
totally disregards the Queen side just
just to try and checkmate
the black king rook a to D 1 we have
rook to e8 and now Bishop captures on d3
- pulse doesn't care for one corn i mean
mama d RF captures captures and now rook
to e4 attacking the Queen Bishop to f4
and now Bishop to e7 again attacking the
Queen Queen to jittery and now before
preparing to push on the Queen side
Knight to g5 we have Bishop captures on
g5 Bishop captures and now Queen to e6
and now with this powerful battery rock
Queen rook on the e-file the mama girl
really doesn't have all that much to
worry about he can simply push a 5 a 4 B
3 and it's it's gonna be it's gonna be
very hard for Topalov to stop those
pawns and it's hard to say if he even
can't stop those pawns but we have h3 to
Paul of makes some breathing room for
Ace King Queen to e5 this move seems to
be the mistake that kind of well the
starting mistake that will cost the
momager of the game in the end you can't
okay you can't capture the pawn here
rock to d7 would be a terrible threat
then you can't really defend f7 anymore
I rock the f8 it will be met with Bishop
to h6 but what you can do is simply push
a 5 a 5 a 4 and then continue pushing
here Queen to e5 was played probably
after defending for so long and I MIDI
our figures okay now I exchange Queens
and I finally defended but topple plays
King to h2 and we have Queen captures
and g3
King captures and now this weird h6 move
h6 move okay you never want to allow
this bishop to come to h6 to fix your
King here and then you would have all
sorts of terrible threat and bang back
rank but sacrificing a pond like this as
the only advantage basically you have
for a piece is being up a couple of
points but the manager of does this so
Bishop captures on h6 and now rook to e1
rook to f6 we have looked back to e6 and
rook back to f2 rook to e2 again
offering to exchange pawns because my
meter wants to exchange a pair of rooks
and then starts starts to push his pawn
rook to d5 and now rook captures an f2
King captures an f2 + f6
my maduro is trying to play g5 to trap
this Bishop on h6 but here Bishop to e3
was played and here in this position
Sharma media I've decided to resign the
game as he does he is up to pawns but
there's really no way to take advantage
of this
only the only two files that are
available to make this black rook active
are taken by the bishop on e3 and the
rook is controlling the D file so
there's not much to be done here for
black and the whites plan is very clear
white simply gonna play King e2 King d3
King c2 and start grabbing all of the
Queen side points and there's really
nothing black can do about this so
chakra mayara decided to call it a day
here and a first win for Veselin Topalov
in this tournament and the first win for
anyone in this tournament Veselin
Topalov draws first blood and I will I
will tell you something more about the
results from this tournament but I will
show one more game very soon from this
tournament and I will then show you the
results and talk a little bit more about
the tournament so we haven't had a game
by Veselin Topalov in a long time so I
do hope you enjoyed it and what a way to
take down a player like Shaq here mommy
Gaurav I don't I don't know if he's
still world number 2 maybe maybe Caruana
took his place but I don't think he did
I think you know I think my Madeira is
still world number 2 by rating and what
away by wrestling to power to take down
such such a monster so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank a mati village and Turkey
consulting for a contribution to my
channel think a lot to really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon with another video
from the regime of Memorial Tournament
thank you all